We are back with another episode
of the Wine Down.
And today we're joined
by the lovely Christina Elmore,
who plays Condola.
And we'll be discussing
"Lowkey Thankful."
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Why do you think Condola doesn't
initially invite Lawrence
to Thanksgiving?
I think that's such
a complicated question.
But I do think, ultimately,
she's being honest
when she says to him,
"I didn't want to feel pressured
and I didn't want you
to feel pressure."
-Mm-hmm.
-I think that we haven't
really gotten to the point yet
where we're talking about like,
meeting families or meeting
even close friends.
-Right.
-And... I just don't feel
-like we're there yet.
-Right.
What was Condola's
thought process?
Did he sort of invite himself
and now Condola feels put upon?
-Yeah.
-PRENTICE PENNY:
What's her feelings
about exposing herself too?
I think when-- I just went
with the Christina perspective,
which is that like,
I would be really mortified
to say, "Hey! Come to my
very special Friendsgiving
with all my very best friends."
And then him be like,
"No, I'm just gonna go get
this Hennessy turkey," like--
-Yeah.
-And so, I think,
he never brings it up,
I never bring it--
Because I think we're both
kind of,
afraid of like being vulnerable
in that way.
Do you guys feel like Lawrence
is more into the relationship
than Condola is?
I'm inclined to say no.
I feel like him saying,
"Oh, I didn't know
you wanted a family," and,
"Oh, I'm ready for this
next step,"
it's more because he's ready
for next steps in his life,
rather than like,
is he actually ready
for a next step with Condola
at this moment?
That's fair.
So, do you think that when
she saw Lawrence and Issa
-at the-- the coffee shop--
-Yeah.
That they're at your spot,
you feel like Condola left that
like feeling secure
in her relationship?
Or do you feel like she left
like, "Oh, there might be
something I have
to worry about here"?
I think it was like one
of the first, like,
chinks in the armor.
It was like,
"Oh, Issa and Lawrence
still have jokes that are funny,
-and that Condola does not get."
-(LAUGHS) That's what hurts.
-It's like...
-That hurts.
"...Y'all are really laughing,
this is not fake pleasantries."
-It's like--
-It's just like, "Oh, yo--"
And like there's wit
and stuff going back and forth.
Do you guys think it's possible
to be friends with your ex
and not have any feelings
for them?
It's possible,
it's not probable.
(LAUGHING)
-I mean...
-I think it's possible.
I think it's possible.
I just don't see the need to,
-I guess.
-I don't see the--
Like, you can have no feelings
for them anymore, sure,
I think that's totally possible.
But if I don't want
-to be with you in that way--
-Yeah.
And I don't have any feelings
for you...
-Why do we want to be friends?
-Yeah.
I'm cool with my exes,
but we don't have conversations.
Like if I saw you in the street
it wouldn't be like, "Die."
It would just be like,
"Oh, hey," joke, joke, joke.
-Keep it pushing.
-I don't know, I just--
Well, I don't want to say.
I don't want to see you
do better than me.
-You wouldn't want-- You don't--
-I don't-- No, no.
I'm the best you got--
ever will have.
Like, I don't want
to see you out there
with like a better dude.
I guess I would never
acknowledge that it was better.
(LAUGHING) I just can't
acknowledge, like--
"Oh, you did that,
that's great."
Yeah, like,
"You got that person--"
(OVERLAPPING CHATTER)
"But they're not,
like, better."
-No.
-No, no.
And I'm not gonna
acknowledge it.
-Like he's too tall.
-(CHUCKLES) Yeah.
Noted.
Having to stand on tip toes
and stuff.
Yeah, he's too--
He's too chiseled, uh-uh.
-That's not real.
-Super secure.
-Prentice Penny, super...
-I write on Insecure.
-(CHUCKLES) secure.
-So, there you go.
Hey, thank you again
for joining us.
See you next time.
Cheers!
(ALL LAUGHING)
Okay.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪